pour la troisième semaine consécutive
des milliers de personnes ont défilé à
travers le pays pour protester une fois
de plus contrôler projet de loi sur la
sécurité globale
une nouvelle journée de mobilisation
globalement maîtrisé grâce à une forte
présence policière
objectif de ce dispositif renforcé
éviter le scénario des manifestations
précédentes marquées par des violences
et des dégradations
quelques incidents tout de même eu lieu
à paris si où les forces de l'ordre ont
procédé à 110 9 interpellations
un cortège parisien dans lequel
figuraient notamment des gilet jaune
dont jérôme rodriguez l'une des figures
du mouvement
ce dernier évoque une loi liberticide
au delà de ces revendications de mettre
à bas la loi de sécurité globale faut
quoi faut se souvenir d'eux pourquoi on
est dans la rue parce que tout est une
relation de cause à effet c'est à dire
on est sortis dans la rue nous citoyens
en colère qui porte un gilet jaune le 17
novembre 2018
et force est de constater qu'on a un
petit peu gêné macron dans le dessein de
son de son de son objectif qu'on il n'a
pas été à la vitesse qu'ils auraient
voulu et que à défaut de pouvoir
contenter l'ensemble du peuple français
de da de d'accéder à nos revendications
il met en place des lois liberticides
dont l'ensemble de la france pâtit
aujourd'hui une mobilisation lancé par
des syndicats et des associations à
laquelle ont également répondu près 2000
marseillais à toulouse 1200 manifestants
ont défilé malgré l'interdiction des
rassemblements qui avait également pour
objectif de dénoncer les violences
policières
a lyon quelques heures sont à relever
deux mille personnes étaient mobilisées
dans la capitale des gaules pour
s'opposer au projet de loi controversé
est une entrave à la liberté d'informer
les gens que la liberté d'expression
général ça fait des années qu'on
manifeste des années qu'on manifeste
qu'on dit qu'on n'est pas d'accord et
ils font passer leur loi petit à petit
pour tenter d'éteindre la polémique sur
ce sujet sensible
emmanuel macron a annoncé cette semaine
l'organisation d'un beauvau de la
sécurité en janvier prochain une
consultation qui devrait réunir
représentants des forces de l'ordre
élus et citoyens